jim est ce que tu allais les cinq
premiers noms les 1 2 3 4 des bandes
dessinées surgi du passé des fanzines
retrouver sur un marché
un samedi matin au marché aux puces
d'orient je suis et ma compagne m'a tant
sur un stand arrêté sur un stand devant
dessinée il ya des milliers de bandes
dessinées commercial et juste devant il
ya un petit carton avec des bandes
dessinées fait à la main des originaux
ça se voit tout de suite et
immédiatement je me dis le gala
quelqu'un qui a fait des bandes
dessinées en s'inspirant de celle du
commerce mais qui les a faites à la main
et je me dis que le carton en est plein
il y en a des centaines ces livres sont
l'oeuvre de norbert moutier un enfant
surdoué qui dessinent et reproduit des
séries américaines avec ses héros
préférés de l'après guerre ça nous
raconte ses bandes dessinées comment un
gamin s'abreuvent d'image de l'amérique
de récits de l'amérique de cow boys
indiens
histoire de science-fiction par moments
d'espionnage de gangsters de héros
masqué des débuts des super héros et
comment lui il aime tellement ça qu'il
rejoue ce à dire qu'il reprend les héros
à son compte et il rejoue on dirait
qu'on touche à la fusée armé d'un
revolver et d'une pile électrique
s'avance nous allons bien voir des
bandes dessinées retrouver une curiosité
pour ces étudiants voir cette démarche
qui peut être qui est très personnelle
pour lui parce qu'il n'avait jamais rien
montrer à personne
mais comment il a pu
autant produit autant
édité autant de choses est aussi
passionné aussi aussi motivé dans ses
travaux le projet immédiat c'est de
travailler avec les étudiants de l'esad
sur une exposition ça c'est le projet
concret il ya plusieurs opportunités
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse une
exposition à orléans mais il ya aussi
des opportunités à paris à lyon
peut-être à bruxelles probablement et
j'espère même pourquoi pas aux états
unis éditeurs libraires cinéaste norbert
mutti c'était à orléans en janvier 2020
c'est fanzine oublié lui offre
aujourd'hui une notoriété posthume